Blair walnuts is in my opinion one of
the most interesting people on this
platform there's really something for
everybody on this channel from how to
get a sugar daddy relationship advice
fashion hauls and celebrity diet
challenges some may call it chaos but
Others May call it some solid creative
range I for one find her a pretty funny
and entertaining mainly because I'm
never really sure if she's trolling all
of us or if it's just really who she is
I guess we will never know but anyway
she is no stranger to my channel here on
Abby's kitchen my first review of her
content in 2020 featured what appeared
to be a solid sense of food Freedom so I
guess I was a bit disappointed a year
later when she posts a now deleted video
packed with disorderly weight loss
advice trigger warning to what I'm about
to say here but the video really read a
bit like a pro Anna Reddit thread Circa
2005 with a bunch of tips on how to
suppress your appetite any less now I
know that Blair has been through her own
Journey including a breakup with her
then fiance so I'm sure it's all not
being easy for her to navigate and after
the whole deleted diet video Fiasco she
actually agreed to appear on my channel
to unpack it before ultimately changing
her mind but since then Blair has had
some time to let the dust settle a bit
and it seems that she's ready to finally
talk and I of course am here to help you
unpack it together hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we'll be catching up with Blair walnuts
and her September video Blair walnuts
weight loss and Ed and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning we will be discussing
Eating Disorders so as always please
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed here guys
help a girl out here hit that subscribe
button follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen and also hit
the little bell thing so that you never
miss out on a video alright kids let's
take a look what's this Blair walnuts
weight loss Blair walnuts Ed Blair
walnuts has an oh that's me I used to
try out celebrity Lifestyles not only
their fitness routines the foods they
ate things got a little out of control
as a fellow content creator I think a
lot of people don't realize that we're
humans too and when we're dealing with
normal human life challenges like a
breakup or mental health struggle it can
be very hard to like put on a happy face
and perform it's not easy for anyone to
kind like live their life in the public
eye but especially when they're going
through something that's particularly
hard and taxing I've really stopped
following strict what I eat in a daze
and diet and fitness routines that don't
really align with my lifestyle I think
I'll do them occasionally as like a
trend for a day but I don't think I
would Implement them in my life because
my brain gets a little confused I think
this is a really good call personally I
don't really get the whole like 30 day
challenges or when creators try to
follow a potentially disorderly or
nonsensical diet to a tea just for the
sake of following a video concept when
you're purposefully ignoring your own
body cues to like emulate someone else's
perfectly of course it's going to
confuse the body and that's why you'll
notice that when I do these kind of like
eat like a celebrity videos I literally
build on the celebrities alleged meals
to turn them into hunger crushing combos
that work specifically for me is sling
doesn't align with my body's needs or
desires I don't do it like I don't even
attempt it period the end That's all
folks the point for me is to really show
people real world examples of the types
of balanced meal suggestions that I've
always made in my videos not to
reinforce like a disorderly or
restrictive celebrity diet and put my
own body through hell in the process
right now I'm just eating what feels
good to my body and intuitively there's
no strict calorie counting or anything
like that okay so it sounds like Blair
is getting Back to Basics by focusing on
the foods that she likes and feel good
to her we love to see it I honestly just
eat what I feel like eating and right
now my obsession is avocado toast I
think it's a really great source of
carbs and fat and protein and if you add
a little bit of hummus in here I think
there would be even more protein today
um but usually this is what I eat and I
eat until I'm full love this and she's
totally right like this is a great
hunger crushing combo and since Blair
used sourdough bread we actually have a
decent amount of protein here so about
16 to 18 grams and if we were to add in
that hummus that Blair mentioned or a
couple poached eggs or hemp parts or we
mashed in some white beans or cottage
cheese in with the avocado we could bump
that protein up even more I watch a lot
of Abby Sharp
I love the impromptu shout out
I'm blushing I made a video about how to
lose weight quickly which I didn't
really put in the most forethought in
which I think was my greatest mistake I
was not doing my greatest when I made
that video it was something that was
like often requested on my channel like
how do I get abs like this how did you
lose weight like this and I kind of just
echoed information that I had from a
bunch of like competing sources like I
had a lot of model friends that gave me
advice I read a bunch of things on the
internet okay so I first want to say
that again creators are human and we all
make mistakes with the volume of content
that we're putting out there like
ultimately we're just bound to slip up
sometimes and I think the important
thing is to recognize when you're wrong
or you misspoke and take action whether
it's removing the video like she did or
re-uploading it with some more context
I've done both of these things here on
my own channel when I realized that I
might have slipped up it's also worth
pointing out that considering Blair is
saying that she wasn't in the best place
when she made the video in the first
place we also don't really know if the
weight loss was completely intentional
or as a result of stress from Life
events often when we're in an
uncontrollable circumstance we look at
all the possible ways that we can
maintain some semblance of control and
often food is one of the easiest parts
of our life to try to manipulate and
this can become a real problem when any
resulting weight loss becomes reinforced
by Praise or external validation as it
seems like was the case from some of her
fans I guess if you saw me in America
you've always thought I was like normal
size but for like Europeans I was like
on the bigger side when I went to South
Korea a lot of the clothes wouldn't even
really fit me so like I was xxxl there
it kind of caused this like cognitive
dissonance in my brain where I didn't
realize if I was big or small and I
didn't really understand how to eat well
because every single culture and every
person has their own different standard
of eating gosh I mean I can totally
imagine that this just out of fuel to
the fire here and these variations in
body standards and body ideals around
the world is strongly influenced by
cultural and socioeconomic differences
and also it's a tendency to change from
generation to generation not
surprisingly unattainable cultural body
standards often is directly correlated
with the prevalence of dieting and
disordered eating with one study in
Eastern Europe specifically suggesting
that the internalization of
sociocultural standards of beauty
increase the risk of Eating Disorders in
Polish teens and whether your culture
celebrates wave thin bodies or curvy
girls with booties bottom line is that
all bodies are going to be unique
everyone in that specific culture cannot
possibly naturally have that preferred
body so the combination of external
praise for weight loss plus conflicting
cultural beauty standards is definitely
a recipe for a tumultuous relationship
with body and food so I really do
empathize with Blair here and we do want
to normalize that even folks with the
healthiest relationships with food and
their body can also have very
challenging body image days as well at
the end of the day my point Still
Remains the Same as it used to be when I
was old Walnut and that's eat when
you're hungry stop when you're full eat
what your body craves and don't eat
things you don't feel like eating
intuitive eating often gets reduced down
to the hunger fullness diet when a
healthy relationship with food is far
more nuanced than this but I think what
Blair is trying to get at here is that
we really shouldn't be depriving
ourselves of basic nourishment and
satisfaction from food for the sake of
achieving some unrealistic body
aesthetic we shouldn't be looking at
what other people are eating and trying
to emulate that so that we can live like
them or look like them because otherwise
it can be very easy to lose sight of
what feels good to our own body and to
our mind as well always full but from
the wrong things so it always have a
craving for something else later today I
have a conspiracy theory that your body
tells you kind of like what you need to
eat so this is what I often call the
satisfaction hunt basically you try to
eat around a craving by replacing it
with like a low calorie or diet friendly
alternative and even if you're
physically full the lack of emotional
satisfaction ends up sending you on a
hunt until you just come like give in
and eat what you truly Crave in the end
you often end up eating far more
calories than had you just honored your
craving in the first place and don't
forget the body is incredibly wise and
is always communicating with us so for
example a lot of us maybe have like an
intense craving for vegetables after
having like an indulgent vacation that
likely is your body telling you that it
needs some extra hydration and maybe
some Fiber after eating a lot of fried
food and booze do you ever crave
something sweet on your period maybe
that's your body telling you that it
could use a little extra hit of
Serotonin do you ever crave a smoothie
or fresh fruit during a really hot day
that could be your body communicating
that it needs some extra water the more
you tune in the more you can begin to
understand your body's unique cues and
signals and as you start to listen and
respond you can slowly start to rebuild
and strengthen that body trust and today
I just so happen to be craving up
pistachio latte and a chicken rice
veggie bowl from one of my favorite
cafes
[Music]
okay this looks like a really beautiful
lunch to enjoy in the Miami Heat we're
getting lots of energizing carbs from
the rice and satrating protein from the
chicken and also some colorful veggie
add-ins like caramelized onions
pineapple carrot and arugula which also
boosts the micronutrient and fiber
content and of course I'm loving the
avocado for an extra dose of healthy
fats and fiber looks awesome
[Music]
I feel like this is a pretty
well-rounded meal like what could you
possibly not like about it love this
Lazy Girl meal I also think that this is
a good example of leaning on Frozen
processed foods for convenience and ease
without sacrificing nutrition we are
getting in our carbs protein fiber and
calories and we're still getting our
veggie fix in fact some frozen
vegetables are often higher in
nutritional value than Fresh Veggies
because they are flash frozen at the
peak of freshness and Perfection so
there's absolutely no shame in the
Frozen veggie game hey that rhymes for
dessert I really like these veggies made
great chocolate muffins because they
have zucchini in them because I really
don't eat enough vegetables normally I
usually just have the chicken nuggets
and french fries and then I had a yogurt
so if you struggle to get your veggies
in throwing them into soups smoothies
sauces and baked goods is an easy way to
bump up your intake and while we don't
exactly know how much zucchini and
carrots we are getting from these little
muffins they are listed as the first two
ingredients in the ingredient list so
basically this tells us that they
represent greater amounts compared to
the other ingredients listed on the
label so we're getting some protein and
fiber from the muffins and some more
protein and fat from the yogurt so looks
like an awesome Hunger crushing Cabo to
me since I've been less stressed about
it I actually have maintained the same
weight that I was and some days I have
abs some days I don't there's like
specific foods that make me more bloated
like if I eat a lot of beans my abs
completely go away can we please
normalize bloat and body weight
fluctuations I mean I've seen way too
many influencers spiral from minor
upticks on the scale and bloating this
is a reminder that is totally normal for
our stomachs to expand after a meal it
is also normal to experience modest
weight gain in response to our menstrual
cycles stress medication bathroom habits
the food we eat is
Etc there is so much to gain when we
stop obsessing over food and our body
weight and normal fluctuations that are
really not meant to be hyper-controlled
it is also normal for us not to have a
six-pack since most menstruating folk
need around 26 to 28 body fat for
hormonal regulation to support
menstruation and fertility and then also
you have to keep in mind when you're
looking at Instagram photos and models
and things like that they prepare for
these photo shoots just like a bikini
competitor prepares for the challenge so
just because they look like this at One
Moment In Time doesn't mean they always
look like this amen please take
everything that you see online with a
grain of salt thanks to filters and
facetune social media makes it
incredibly easy to curate an unrealistic
image that really does not represent
real life and it's no surprise that
increased social media use has been
associated with low self-esteem negative
body image and an increased prevalence
of disordered eating comparison is truly
the thief of joy and I think that we can
all attest to that after like a long IG
scroll sesh so this is just a reminder
to practice good social media hygiene as
a form of self-care because being
exposed to unrealistic body standards on
a regular basis can turn toxic real
[ __ ] quick don't take this as
inspiration I wouldn't follow random
YouTubers what I eat in a day I would
like look at what I eat in a days and
diet videos as kind of inspo for new
foods you haven't tried before or like a
combination of like flavors that you
haven't tried I love this I mean I feel
like Blair maybe has been watching my
content because I say this all the time
I watch a lot of Abby sharp that is a
core message that I try to communicate
every single time I do a review I know
that given the strange parasocial
relationships that we develop with our
favorite content creators that it can be
very hard not to want to emulate their
diet and fitness regimens especially if
you admire how they look and again
content creators are human too we all
make mistakes but we also have an
enormous responsibility for what we put
out there and we cannot underestimate
its impact or influence so I really
respect that Blair was able to take that
responsibility discuss it openly and
share her own journey to securing a
healthier relationship with food and on
that note that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video please
be sure to give it the thumbs up
subscribe to this channel if you're not
already and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]